[Musica]
no
fin da quando ero bambino io ho sempre
amato tantissimo leggere ogni anno per
la grande gioia di tutte le statistiche
istat
io leggo più di 200 romanzi e libri in
generale fumetti esclusi sono laureato
in lettere e il mio percorso di
dottorato si è inserito negli studi
umanistici
fatte queste premesse quindi perché sono
qui a parlarvi di videogiochi perché per
me anche il videogioco rientra nella
cultura e parlo proprio di quella
cultura con la c maiuscola quella che
tutti noi quando ci pensiamo associamo
immediatamente ai libri a questi
meravigliosi oggetti che ci permettono
di apprendere ma anche di emozionarci al
tempo stesso ma quando io penso a questi
due concetti che vi ho appena citato le
emozioni e l'apprendimento
la seconda cosa cui io penso sono
proprio i videogiochi che sono sempre
stati la mia altra grande passione
a me è capitato talvolta di commuovermi
con le storie di un protagonista di un
videogioco
talvolta ho ripensato per giorni e
giorni a quelle vicende che avevo appena
vissuto e io ritrovavo al loro interno
le stesse emozioni che mi davano i miei
libri preferiti
certo in forma differente ma le stesse e
pensiamo del resto a quanto possa essere
forte ed emotivamente coinvolgente
una storia che noi viviamo in prima
persona in cui siamo noi con le nostre
scelte
a determinare un percorso
a livello emotivo è un qualcosa di
incredibile ma spesso nei discorsi sui
videogiochi
questo aspetto è totalmente trascurato o
se ne parla solo per i suoi lati
negativi
ed ecco quindi i videogiochi violenti i
videogiochi che bloccano la creatività
dei bambini i videogiochi che danno
dipendenza e in tutti questi casi c'è
anche un fondo di verità
ma ciò che emerge è quella solita
vecchia retorica che abbiamo già visto
tante volte applicate ai fumetti alla
televisione al cinema alla letteratura
stessa secondo cui si parte da
situazioni specifiche e le utilizza per
spiegare un intero paradigma e questo è
un peccato anche perché viene fatto il
più delle volte da persone che neanche
conoscono il videogioco è nemmeno
vogliono farlo e non sanno quindi cosa
si perdono cosa potrebbero scoprire se
andassero un po sotto quella che è la
superficie
facciamo un piccolo esempio
secondo voi quante persone conoscono un
videogioco come depression quest che è
stato creato per spiegare per far vivere
a livello emotivo cosa prova una persona
che soffre di depressione sono ben pochi
anche fra gli stessi videogiocatori
fidatevi
oppure quanti hanno perlomeno sentito la
storia di quel padre che ha deciso di
raccontare proprio tramite un video
gioco della morte di suo figlio malato
di cancro sono solo due dei tanti esempi
che potremmo fare ma già ci fanno capire
quanto possano essere varie e profonde
le emozioni che noi abbiamo in un
videogioco e che possono darci anche una
valenza educativa pedagogica e qui
torno all'altro termine che vi citavo
prima l'apprendimento magari
dall'esterno non sembra ma i videogiochi
sono un ottimo strumento per apprendere
se così non fosse non si capirebbe
perché in questi ultimi anni in così
tanti contesti una delle parole magiche
sia diventata gainey fiction che
significa semplicemente prendere delle
meccaniche ludiche e portarle in un
contesto non ludico e questo succede
perché funziona perché quando noi siamo
divertiti da qualcosa ci sentiamo più
facilmente ingaggiati siamo più portati
ad apprendere perché non ci rendiamo
neanche conto che stiamo facendo uno
sforzo di qualche genere
già da questo possiamo immaginare quante
siano le possibilità culturali che un
videogioco ci offre già tuttora abbiamo
videogiochi che promuovono il turismo
abbiamo videogiochi legati alle
biblioteche e ai musei
abbiamo videogiochi che permettono a dei
professionisti di determinati settori di
sperimentare in un contesto protetto le
operazioni che andranno poi a dover fare
in futuro per davvero
il videogioco insomma e tante cose e se
noi ci limitiamo a valutarlo per quelli
che sono gli esempi di cui tutti parlano
quotidianamente finiremmo per ridurlo
così come potremmo ridurre tutta la
letteratura ai due tre romanzi di
maggior successo del momento
anzi sarebbe come ridurre tutta la
produzione editoriale a questi due tre
romanzi invece sappiamo tutti benissimo
che è sufficiente andare in una
qualsiasi biblioteca per trovare sui
suoi scaffali non solo i romanzi ma
anche saggi libri di cucina manuali che
ci spiegano come fare cose e questa
stessa ricchezza
la troviamo anche nei videogiochi e
visto che vi citavo le biblioteche
quanti di voi sanno che anche qui in
italia in questi luoghi stanno entrando
i videogiochi
fate una prova andate nella vostra
biblioteca e chiedete se hanno dei
videogiochi nel loro catalogo e se non
dovessero averli proponetegli di
acquisirli nella mia visione queste
biblioteche sono da sempre i luoghi in
cui tutti i saperi tutte le forme di
cultura si trovano insieme e quindi è
giusto che anche il videogioco possa
trovare il suo spazio e il suo
riconoscimento e potremmo allora trovare
lì sia i videogiochi di nicchia quelli
meno noti che però magari è utile far
conoscere ma anche i videogiochi di
grande successo che hanno comunque molto
da offrirci
pensiamo anche solo a quante persone e
alcune le ho conosciute anch'io che per
spiegare certi periodi storici
utilizzano assassin's creed videogioco
di grandissimo successo commerciale è
molto noto per le sue ricostruzioni
storiche e oggi noi abbiamo assassin's
creed ma un domani forse avremo qualcosa
a cui noi stessi abbiamo contribuito
perché la creazione di un videogioco non
è solo programmazione creare un
videogioco vuol dire anche arte vuol
dire cultura e noi in italia siamo
ricchissimi di queste cose e siamo anche
ricchi di giovani e talentuosi
sviluppatori che vogliono mettersi in
gioco in questo senso quindi possiamo
tutti quanti lavorare insieme per creare
questi nuovi videogiochi del domani che
possano sempre più interfacciarsi anche
con la cultura
io per esempio da letterato sogno di
vedere ottimi e bellissimi video giochi
sui classici della nostra letteratura e
non solo
e possiamo farlo non lasciamo che siano
solo i libri per quanto strumenti
meravigliosi a trasmettere la nostra
cultura
le storie che da sempre ci emozionano e
ci fanno imparare hanno la loro bellezza
proprio nel fatto che si ripresentano in
modi sempre diversi
quindi le possibilità con cui noi
possiamo trovare queste storie possiamo
fruirle è una ricchezza non dovrebbe
essere limitata lasciatemi pertanto
chiudere con un invito se siete
videogiocatori se amate i videogiochi
iniziate a tenere un bel libro sul
comodino e se amate la letteratura
trovate un video gioco le emozioni che
troverete saranno le stesse e avrete la
stessa bellezza
[Applauso]
[Musica]